**Thunder**
**Splash**
**Dog laugh**
**Music**
Hello Internet! Welcome to Film Theory!
The show that's gone barking mad!
Today we're heading back into
the wonderful world of Bluey.
The hit animated show coming to
us live from the land down under.
Now in case you've missed out on this one,
Bluey's all about a family
of dogs known as the Heelers.
There's Bluey, her sister Bingo,
her father Bandit, and her mum Chilli.
Each 8 minute episode sees them
engaging in simple everyday adventures
like playing keepy-uppy with a balloon
or preparing for the family barbecue.
All in a way that's super fun for
kids and super relatable for adults.
This is great! They're learning a
lesson and we get the house clean!
But what's really made Bluey
iconic are the episodes
that focus on the wild imagination
games that the family plays.
Which range from whale watching,
to pretending there's a fairy
causing mischief in the house,
to their dad acting as a human claw machine.
Insert coin for awesome prizes.
Legitimately this is one of the best
animated kids shows that I've seen in years.
Tackling all the joys and stresses
that are both childhood and parenting
in like the purest way possible.
It is so good.
True story, I started watching the
show with Ollie about a year ago
and while he's now graduated up
into the world of Gravity Falls,
I am so proud of you buddy,
I'm still late night binging episodes of Bluey
and relating hard to Bandit.
But the more I watch, the more
one question lingers in my mind.
Is magic real in this world?
You see, the imagination on display
as the characters play their games
really goes to the next level.
Like really!
These characters are incredibly
invested in their backyard adventures.
Whether it's something like
a very aggressive puppet,
We can handle this Mum!
Unicorse!
Ow! My back! My neck!
My back and my neck! Whiplash!
Call my lawyer!
To something as elaborate as becoming an
escaped monkey rampaging through the yard.
Would you like to see our reptile section?
And while most of it can be
written off as just parents
committing to the bit to like the nth degree,
there are other moments in the show
that seem impossible to believe.
Like the episode where the kids literally learn
to use magic to influence their surroundings.
Or when Bingo uses a feather
wand to turn everything heavy.
Cereal heavy!
What's going on?
And as you really watch the show, more and
more of these strange things keep popping up.
These imaginary games seem to have
a ridiculous amount of influence
on both the characters and the world around them.
Enough so that I just kind of have to ask,
Is magic real in Bluey?
Are all of these games actually the
result of the characters casting spells,
hexes, and charms on each other?
Well, after digging back into the world of Bluey
and pulling out some classic Theorist tricks,
I believe that I can definitively
prove the answer to be yes.
Grab your wands and sticky geckos, friends,
as we dig into the bonafide evidence of
the magical conspiracy taking
place in the world of Bluey.
Now, on the surface, you might look at a bunch of
these games and just think that it's
the imagination of children at work.
That they're just very invested in their games.
But there's commitment, and
then there's just going way
beyond what you'd expect to come
out of real kids at these ages.
Like, to the point that these
games don't feel like a bunch
of toddlers playing make-believe games anymore.
And this is firmly on display from
the very first episode of the series.
In episode one, Magic Xylophone,
we see Bluey and Bingo playing with a
xylophone that can freeze anyone in place.
They just straight up stop,
mid-step and mid-sentence.
At first, Bingo and Bluey
use the xylophone to freeze
Bandit in place and play some pranks on him.
And he commits to the bit so much that
he's frozen when the kids aren't around.
And the neighbors start giving him funny looks.
Now, to be fair, you could
absolutely just chalk that
up to a good old dad playing along with the kids.
But here's the thing.
Later in the episode,
Bingo gets upset because Bluey won't
let her have a turn with the xylophone.
And when she finally gets a hold of it later on
in the episode, Bingo uses it to freeze Bluey.
And it works.
If Bluey truly wants the xylophone as badly
as she does, and doesn't want to play along,
this seven-year-old girl,
she could just easily break the rules
of the game and take it from Bingo.
But she doesn't.
Instead, she gets a pretty serious
heart-to-heart with Bingo while frozen.
Now, this wouldn't be such a big deal
if this was just a one-off event.
But it's not.
This sort of extreme imagination game is
a common occurrence throughout the series.
In the episode, Feather Wand, again,
this is the one where Bingo uses
a feather to turn things heavy,
we see her turn the toilet seat heavy just as
her dad's getting ready to do his business.
And instead of breaking from the game, he
chooses to run downstairs and relieve himself,
Well, it's unclear where exactly, but
it's implied to be in the front yard,
based on Chilli's scream and
Bandit greeting the neighbor.
Bandit! What are you doing?
Morning, Wendy!
I mean, you could be committed to a game, sure.
But in this moment, Bandit's exposing himself to
his loved ones and his neighbors
in a completely inappropriate way.
Public indecency is literally a crime.
Are you doing that just for the sake of an
imagination game for your
four- and seven-year-old?
Speaking of being inappropriate, there are also
instances like the season two episode Dance Mode,
where the kids are given three chances to
flick one of their parents' tails and say,
Dance Mode!
which forces the parent to
dance no matter where they are.
Seems like it should be a fun game, right?
Well, it would be if the kids didn't decide to
use it on Chilli when she's crossing the road.
Ooh, shake it, Chilli!
Morning, Wendy!
Now, obviously, this is super embarrassing
for Chilli, but look at her dance moves.
If she were truly in full control of her
body and wanted to get out of the situation,
she could turn away from the crowd of
cars so she doesn't have to face them,
or use moves that move her further
along in the street faster.
Instead, she's shaking her thing
in front of Wendy's windshield.
Wendy apparently is just the recipient of
a lot of these embarrassing Heeler moments.
Now, again, if this was just a one-off
event, we could just ignore it,
but it happens again to Bandit in the post office.
Uh, are you okay?
I'm fine. Just ignore this.
This right here?
It's just disrespectful to both the store clerk
and the massive line of people waiting behind him.
Even when the store clerk politely asks
him to stop, Bandit says that he can't.
If you could just stop dancing for a moment.
I would if I could, mate.
Oi! Twinkle Toes! Hurry up!
It's either magic, or the Heelers just suck.
And it's here, when the games start
to affect their everyday lives,
when you really start to see the
pretend nature of the games break down.
For instance, let's take a look
at Season 3's episode Sheepdog,
where Bandit pretends to be a sheep to distract
the kids away from bothering their mum.
But here's the thing.
When Bluey isn't looking, Sheep
Bandit still decides to break
into Wendy's yard and start eating her laundry.
He even headbutts her in the rear end
when she threatens to bring in Chili.
That right there, again, is a level of
commitment that's either the result of magic,
or just extreme irresponsibility
on the part of Bandit.
Also, seriously, Wendy has got
to be the most patient neighbor
ever to be living next to these public nuisances.
But the thing that really decides it, is that
even when the kids stop playing the game,
Bandit doesn't drop the act.
He is still acting like a sheep 20 minutes later,
while his kids have been upstairs
playing with the neighbor,
and his wife is just wrapping up her alone time.
Is everything okay?
Yep, all good here.
Why is he still doing it when everyone
else has moved on from the game?
But perhaps most compelling
of all is Daddy Drop-Off,
when Bandit has to take the kids
to school and they're running late.
And yet, just as he's running to the car,
Bingo finds a leaf and uses it
to trap Bandit in slow motion.
Rack him and stack him, kids, we've got gooo...
If Bandit's late getting his kids to school,
you'd think that he'd just ignore
the game and get them in the car.
That'd be the responsible thing.
He could make something up about how
school negates the imaginary game,
or how this leaf isn't actually a magic wand,
or literally anything so he can do the responsible
thing and get his kids to school on time.
But again, he acts like there isn't a choice here.
He acts like he's been under a magic spell.
The slow motion spell is only released
when Bingo waves the wand again,
leading to Bandit smacking into his car.
But hold on.
Bandit is released from the spell
when Bingo waves the wand, sure,
but she's standing behind him.
If this were truly a pretend game,
there's no physical way he'd be able
to know when she waved that wand.
We don't even see his eyes moving or
tracking behind him to look at her.
Watch the clip again.
In fact, we can actually go one step deeper.
Here's the scene in a video editor where
we can see the visuals and audio track.
Check this out.
Bingo saying, "yah"
and the wand wave sound effect,
they're right here.
They're actually occurring after the
wand is waved and Bandit's released.
This right here shows us that
there's no way Bandit would know
to have sped back up again
based on sound or visual cues.
It can only be explained using real magic.
And this is how we know magic
exists in the real world.
For real life?
Yeah, Bluey, for real life.
Because we get physical proof of magic existing.
Like here, where Bingo sneaks into the bathroom,
heavies Bluey's toothbrush without her hearing,
and it just magically works.
Up to this point, Bluey hasn't
been a part of the game,
so she wouldn't know that
things are meant to be heavy.
And while she could just be
pretending to not see or hear Bingo,
the way her reactions are animated
certainly seems to indicate that
Bluey is unaware of anything that's going on.
But the piece of evidence that really seals it,
the one that is irrefutable and definitely
proves that magic exists in this world,
happens a bit later that same episode.
At the top of the episode, we watch
as Bingo uses the feather wand
to make her dad's cereal
box, bowl, and spoon heavy,
forcing them all to the floor.
And throughout the episode, we check in on
Bandit as he attempts to prepare his breakfast.
But there is one moment
that absolutely stands out.
What's wrong, Bandit?
You used to be able to lift spoons.
Did you catch it?
Here, as Bandit tries to use this broom and
rugby ball to pry the spoon off the floor,
the broom physically bends.
And that ball is squeezed under
the heavy weight of the spoon.
And we see the broom bend starting at the spoon.
There is no way that this could happen
if the spoon was at its normal weight.
Literally no physical way for that to happen.
Therefore, the feather wand actually
had to have worked on that spoon,
giving us even more definitive proof that
magic actually exists in the Bluey-verse.
And that suddenly puts other
episodes into a whole new context.
For instance, in the Season 1 episode, Fairies,
the Heeler household is bombarded with
shenanigans brought about by the dreaded fairies.
You know what this means?
What?
We've got fairies!
Now, a lot of this episode is framed
as Bandit trying to make up to Bingo
for ignoring her earlier in the day.
And on a surface level, you
might just watch this episode
and think that the parents are making
the magic happen for their kids.
But for as much as the parents here could have
made some of the things in the episode happen,
there is no way they did all of it.
For instance, midway through the
episode, everyone's hiding in the closet
and Bingo is tasked with finding clues
as to what the fairies might want
in order to leave them alone.
When she returns sometime later, the
house's sitting room is a disaster.
Toys and trash are scattered everywhere.
Figurines are hanging from the ceiling.
Koalas? Just chillin'.
Like I said, this is an Australian show.
It's implied that Bingo was the one
doing all this, but there's just no way.
In order to hang those koalas from the walls
and that shoe in the middle of the room,
she would have needed a stepladder that's
at minimum eight times her own height.
And for as much as Chilli and Bandit disregard
the needs and safety of their fellow neighbors,
I don't think that even they would
allow their favorite four-year-old
to use something like that unsupervised.
But still, that little bit's happening off-camera.
What about something that's
happening on-camera in real time?
That'd be pretty convincing, right?
Well, in that very same episode, after discovering
a fairy ring with Bandit's phone inside,
they turn around and find that the entire
yard has been covered in fairy rings.
There is no way that Bandit and
Chilli could have set all of these up.
We see them in literally every
scene leading up to this big reveal.
And if those rings had already been there,
Bingo and Bluey would have already seen them.
And if they're just pretending to not see them,
you wouldn't get a Bingo
reaction looking like this.
Her eyes are huge.
She is shooketh by those rings.
But we don't just have to assume here either.
Again, we get physical proof that
they weren't there a second ago.
While the camera does its
best to try and frame out
the rest of the yard for the bulk of the scene,
look at where Bluey's standing
relative to that first fairy ring.
If you map her position out relative
to the wide shot that we later cut to,
technically we should have been
able to see that tablet fairy
ring in the bottom right corner of the screen.
But it's not there.
Until Bluey notices all the rest
of the fairy rings across the yard.
This had to have been done using magic.
So, am I saying that fairies
exist in the Bluey-verse?
You bet I am!
At the end of the episode, Bingo straight
up sees a fairy setting up her dominoes
in the same heart shape
that Bingo made for her dad.
While it could just be imaginary, and the show
tries to leave it open for interpretation,
all the physical proof we have from bending
brooms to fairy rings to slow
motion wands prove otherwise.
And now that we have a couple undeniable pieces
of proof that magic exists here, so what?
I mean, that's crazy and all, but
why should we care about this?
Well, we can actually track the source
of the magic, and it's none other than...
If you look back through all
the episodes and evidence,
you'll realize that many of the imaginary
games played throughout the series
are actually all created by
Chilli using some form of magic.
Some examples?
In Asparagus, Chilli gives Bluey
a piece of asparagus and explains,
It's a magic asparagus. It turns
people into any animal you want.
Chilli's whispering this to Bluey, so Bandit and
Bingo can't hear her and know what the game is.
And yet, when Bluey shouts,
Donkey!
Bandit immediately turns into a donkey.
Chilli's created a magic item and is teaching her
kids to do the same all throughout the series.
Magic that, again, goes a bit too far when Bluey
transforms her dad from a peacock to a walrus
and causes him to tumble out
of a tree, landing on his back.
That's not playing along for the funsies.
That is risking severe personal injury.
Additionally, Chilli's often shown to be able to
control the magic within the games
that Bluey and Bingo come up with.
In the episode Magic, when Chilli sees
Bluey and Bingo using magic on Bandit,
the kids run and she's able to stop them.
Who taught you how to use magic?
In fact, Bluey just straight up confirms
that she learned to use her magic from Mum.
You use magic?
Magic?
Yeah, you can use it to make people do anything.
Mum taught me.
Honestly, I could go on and on.
Like in the ending of that very same episode,
where Bingo uses magic to sit her dad
down and force her mum to the door,
all without Dad looking.
Regardless, I think that the one
big key takeaway of all of this
is whether it's extreme pretend or real magic,
the Heelers would suck to
have in your neighborhood.
Oh sure, this magical family
may seem charming to all of
us happiness-starved children of the internet
for their love and commitment to play,
but that's us looking in from the
outside, removed from the situation.
As we've seen here today, this
one family disrupts the flow
of daily life for literally everyone around them.
Whether it's in the line at the post office,
or when you're trying to dry
your laundry in the front yard,
or when your name is Lucky's dad and you're
getting mauled by magical crocodiles,
Get it off me!
attacked by magical snakes,
Snakes!
Get it off me!
or just gnawed by lions.
Aw, Mrs. Heeler,
I dunno know about this.
Imagine how it would feel to
have your adult neighbor pop
out of a bush and start gnawing at your foot.
There's childlike whimsy
and spreading a joy, sure,
and then there's assault of your fellow human.
Uh, fellow dog creature thing.
So while it might seem to be all
fun and games for Bluey and Bingo,
living close to these monsters
would be literally anything but.
But hey, that's just a theory.
A film theory!
And cut!